the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now
a wallpaper for your smartphone now
you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to theminimalists.com
before
to download your free wallpaper today
what's the difference between
decluttering and going
minimalist okay so i i hear i have i
think i have an answer for this
this is like asking what is the
difference between hammering a nail and
becoming a carpenter
um right yeah i could see that and so so
decluttering is one of the tools in your
tool bed about in a very important one
one might even argue the hammer is the
most important tool for the carpenter to
have
right there are other important ones in
there obviously
but the the most versatile everyday tool
for the minimalist is decluttering
yeah they're a bunch of different ways
multi-purpose it's a multi-purpose tool
right because there are different rules
and everything there but
the minimalist is is a broader statement
than that a minimalist in terms of
lifestyle i'm not talking about
minimalist art like donald judd or
or angus martin or or uh
minimalist literature like laurie moore
bradystone ellis
these are different things uh they're
minimalist in their own
fields what we're talking about is
minimalism in terms of well-being or
lifestyle
right and and i think that type of
minimalist
uses the tool of decluttering but they
use a bunch of other
tools as well to live an intentional
life mindfulness
their relationships with their self
their relationship with
the truth all the things we talk about
and love people use things
and they use that tool of decluttering
to remove the excess
to focus on what's actually important
yeah i love that man yeah i mean i use
it
to i don't know to like
develop and i continue to develop the
power of letting go
and you know ultimately when you can let
go of those
those desires that we know aren't going
to make us happy in the long run you
talked about it earlier
uh we can live a more meaningful life
and that's what it's about for me it's
about
uh getting the excess out of the way so
not just the excess stuff but the excess
desires
getting all of that out of the way so i
can focus on what is truly
important and you know what sometimes i
move something out of the way
and later on i'm like oh you know what
actually that is important
yeah i shouldn't move that out of the
way and that's okay but that's but
that's
the journey that uh that you and i are
on
absolutely and i think you bring up a
good point decluttering it often
we think about it as stuff because
physical clutter is when we think about
when we think of clutter but
decluttering goes beyond
even the stuff right you can declutter
your relationships
yeah i remember in our first book
minimalism we wrote about the three
different types of relationships
the primary the secondary and the
tertiary what we call the peripheral
relationships and reorganizing those
relationships in an effective way allows
us to remove
that clutter and that relational clutter
it's not that we
think people are bad or evil or whatever
but if we spend all of our time
with co-workers and acquaintances we
don't have
that precious time to spend with the
people who are closest to us the ones we
love
and so relationship clutter is a big one
health
clutter i think creative clutter all of
these distractions we have
digital clutter we can declutter all of
these things and it is a tool
in order to live a more minimalist or
even if you don't like the term
minimalist the more
simple life it's so funny dude like
we're the minimalists
you know because the domain was
available for seven bucks
but it's funny how it was hard for me to
own that for a while yeah
because it you know it just sounds so um
extreme right but you know i mean that's
i've like obviously grown comfortable
with it um but yeah i mean
it's it's it's just the label and you
know labels are important to an extent
yeah but when it comes to living a good
life you put whatever label you want on
it
right whatever you want to call it